la santé avec le coup d'envoi demain du
sidaction trois jours de présence et
d'appel aux dons sur les principales
chaînes de radio et de télévision voici
ce soir l'une des raisons d'espérer
l'afrique subsaharienne vous le savez
concentre deux tiers environ des cas
recensés dans le monde et dans certains
pays
et bien la prévention a permis de
diminuer très nettement la transmission
du virus de la mère à l'enfant au kenya
reportage dominique derda frédéric
ranque à ses amis elle a fait croire que
c'est parce qu'elle n'avait pas assez de
lait pour allaiter son fils qu'elle
utilisait du lait en poudre
la vérité c'est qu'elle est séropositive
et qu'elle avait peur de le contaminer
si elle lui donnait le sein ici
aujourd'hui encore les porteurs du virus
du sida sont des parias voilà pourquoi
elle n'a pas voulu nous dire son nom et
nous a demandé de cacher leurs visages
si jamais quelqu'un comme un voisin
prenait que je suis séropositive qu'il
s'empresserait de le répéter tout le
monde qu'on me livrerai du doigt et tous
se détourneraient de moi même ceux qui
sont les plus proches à l'hôpital
catholique de nazareth sur les hauteurs
de banana il depuis bientôt cinq ans on
met tout en oeuvre pour tenter de
réduire les risques de transmission du
virus de la mère à l'enfant
et ça marche le taux de transmission
avons était de 35 à 45% bateaux étaient
les programmes que nous avons décidé de
suivre nous ont permis de faire baisser
ce taux à moins de 5% accrue vers l'est
après un test de dépistage systématique
et anonymes les femmes enceintes
séropositives sont prises en charge par
une équipe spécialisée
on leur explique que rien n'est perdu
bien au contraire mais que pour sauver
leurs enfants à venir il va falloir
qu'elle suive un traitement avant
pendant et après l'accouchement
grâce à l'aide internationale les
antirétroviraux sont disponibles en
quantité pour elles et leur futur bébé
ce qui manque c'est l'argent l'argent
pour leur donner de quoi prendre le bus
et venir à l'hôpital subir de nombreux
examens tout au long de leur grossesse
l'argent pour qu'elles accouchent par
césarienne plutôt que par les voies
naturelles c'est plus sûr l'argent enfin
pour payer le lait en poudre que ces
femmes souvent ont bien du mal à
s'offrir
cécilia ne sait pas encore si sa petite
fille de trois jours sera ou non
séropositives il faut six semaines au
moins pour qu'elle développe ses propres
anticorps
mais elle a confiance mais nous le dit
sans crainte à visage découvert a manqué
mais elle elle sera négative
because parce que j'ai bien pris tous
les médicaments qu'on m'a dit de prendre
parce qu'on a utilisé des contraceptifs
comme les docteurs m'ont dit de faire
alors oui maintenant je suis sûr qu'il
sera négative comme on y lit à travers
le pays des dizaines de centres médicaux
comme celui de nazareth
le taux de réussite n'est peut-être pas
aussi élevées mais partout l'espoir de
vaincre un jour la maladie est plus fort
que jamais